[Music]
what is the fundamental unit of life
or in other words what is the building
block of an organism's body
the cell that's absolutely right
cells make up the bodies of all living
organisms
how many cells do you think an organism
needs to live
one two hundreds
well now that depends on the organism we
are talking about
an organism like amoeba is made up of
only a single cell
yes you heard it right just one single
cell constitutes the body of an amoeba
this cell carries out all the functions
of this organism's body
be it respiration digestion locomotion
and excretion
what about a cat or a dog
do they have a single cell
of course they don't
they have many cells which make up the
entire body
there are groups of cells which carry
out different functions
for example
all cells of type a will carry out the
function of respiration and cells of
type b will carry out the process of
digestion but what are these groups of
cells called
do they have a specific name
yes each cluster of cells is called a
tissue
and each tissue carries out a specific
function
such organisms with many tissues are
called multicellular organisms
multicellular organisms have tissues in
their bodies which are placed at
specific places to carry out specific
functions
this is called division of labor in the
organism's body
can you give me a few examples of
tissues in the human body
the muscles
yes the muscles are tissues that help
movement by contraction and relaxation
what about blood
do you know that blood is a tissue
yes blood helps transport nutrients
hormones and waste materials as well
blood is the connective tissue of the
human body
let us look at plants now
do you think plants have tissues too
are the tissues of plants and animals
similar
do you think plants need the same
tissues as humans
logically they do not have the same
tissues as humans do
but they do have tissues
let us see what the considerable
differences between the two are
do plants move from one place to another
like humans do
no right
plants are stationary and their movement
is restricted
so a closer look at a plant tissue will
make you realize that most of them have
dead tissues
yes dead tissues and why do you think
plants need dead tissues
the answer is quite simple
plants only need mechanical support
hence they do not need living tissues
dead tissues serve the purpose of giving
support to plants and they need very
little maintenance
what about animals
do animals move
yes animals move from place to place and
they need tissues for purposes more than
just physical
almost all tissues and animals are
living tissues
these tissues need nutrition which they
get from the organism's body
what else could be a possible difference
between the two
do you know that there are two types of
tissues in plants
one type of tissue divides throughout
its lifetime while the other type of
tissue does not have the ability to
divide
what is the purpose of such a
differentiation
well plants do not grow uniformly
throughout their body
their growth is restricted to some
specific parts
in these parts we find the tissues which
can divide
on the other hand there are parts which
do not grow beyond a specific limit
they have the non-dividing tissues
can this apply to the human or the
animal body of course not
humans and animals exhibit uniform
growth throughout their body
therefore animals have tissues that
divide spread throughout their body
parts
they do not have these two types of
tissues
in our further videos we shall look at
what these tissues are called as well as
the characteristics of each type of
tissue
you